those guys who post a shirtless like
naked selfies like those are not the
ones that you want to go on a date with
it's like it's cool if you're on a beach
with some friends and like if it's like
you and your car being like walking back
to guy moved me Josh and chase and today
we're joined by the face of Paco Rabanne
XS and that's Kowski holiday oh my god
hurry up I'm great great to see you
again the perfect scald XS mm-hmm what's
the most excessive thing about you
the fact that I'm wearing a wig saying
the fact that I love wigs so much like
yeah pretty excessive I would say I mean
they're different characters right you
are yeah yeah totally it's like so fun
for me um like I have my birthday coming
up wigs are encouraged to my party like
please be accessible with me what kind
of bride why yeah cuz I'm guessing you
want like a pink dress I was not a
Pinterest bride I mean for me I do so
much glam it was just so nice to be able
to throw on like this are a suit that I
love do my own makeup do my own hair
don't like show up at the courthouse and
just not have to have the fluffiness and
then I love weddings and I couldn't do a
lot of them and I just feel like a lot
of people don't end up enjoying their
wedding because they're so stressed
about planning and like this moment and
it was really just for him and I which
was really special and like I'm so
excited that party where we can like
share it with everyone but before the
world found out we have like four hours
of just like us doing this thing now
we're gonna play a game called be more
Emily cuz I will be more like you I want
to feel empowered like you displaying
fragrance itself okay I just do that
let's do it Paco Brown is all about
sensuality how can I raise my sensuality
game mm-hmm
sensuality game I think I'm sick of this
word but confidence is very important
and you're not going to be central to
anyone if you don't feel good in your
own skin that's the truth it doesn't
matter what you look like
I think we can all agree when a girl or
our guy is working it and you can just
tell they're feeling themselves and they
dress it's just uniquely then that
there's nothing sexier than that what
would you say to young girls out there
in this really pressurized social media
environment yeah what would you tell
them about how to get through those
difficult times I think as hard as it is
you have to learn to not rely on the
positive feedback as much as you don't
regard the negative feedback
there's gonna be 10 different people
telling you that you're beautiful and
then they'll be two that are saying you
look awful and if you care too much
about the people who are saying that you
look really beautiful than the people
who say you don't well we're really
sting so it's really about you know I
love the selfie I'll share whatever but
like the feedback shouldn't be what
defines your confidence if you're happy
then I need to update my tinder game
we're looking getting a bit better here
this is actually real life probably
right
hmm I think not overthinking it is so
key because my friends obsess on their
five pick these are the truth that's
like no one's gonna get a real sense of
UI pictures so don't obsess and like
doing look hot here whatever because we
all know that like those guys supposed
to shirtless like naked selfies like
those are not the ones that you want to
go on a date with it's like it's cool if
you're on a beach with some friends like
if it's like you and your car being like
okay a builder cackles yay okay how long
stop it really depends what they say
because like I don't mind if someone's
like let's really go today yeah thanks
like sometimes we need that like I like
that through other times I'm like please
don't harass me in public when I want to
be left alone
yeah but I generally find just not
giving them anywhere
best best thing looks like we can get on
with life girls there we go there's no
way is it the season of the unta beef or
the side boob or plate at the same time
top boob under boob side boob Oh Oh
always on trend especially in the summer
take those boxes yeah
I'm suffering from quite low body
confidence the same hypotheticals okay
I'm quite empowered today good you look
great
yeah what's the positive message I can
turn myself in the mirror before I head
out don't be so hard on yourself you're
up your own worst critic no one else is
thinking about you in that way and the
better you feel about yourself it's
better that the world will see you a lot
of people think Oh like you know she's
so confident and like doesn't deal with
this stuff looks like that's absolutely
crazy like everyone goes to the Sun I
have days where I'm just like I
literally came all over Mars I'm so sick
of myself it's just important to
remember but those days are going to
come and then the next day you're
amazing yeah that's already made we're
in France what would be your best
friend's shop line oh my god like
something about wine or cheese or bread
like you you know you track it a line
anymore go to the bread yeah that's
where girl it is right I mean it's all I
care about
other than wigs a troll has go out of
control on Instagram happens how can I
shut them down ignore them and then if
you feel necessary to say something like
wait 24 hours hmm calm down a glass of
wine go do something fun with your
friends whatever and then make it just
like long go long
nice try I think Kim Kardashian is the
Queen and just like so confident and
like you know nothing you get on her and
she's always ahead of it and just like
Lowell everyone they're trying to troll
me so I'll literally like be like
because you can't be here I love it all
you don't care
you
[Applause]
[Music]